Ted you'd mentioned in a prior interview
that it's not just a great script a
great you know movie idea but how does a
producer and director know that they
want to work with each other for two
years five years six years what are some
of the things that you've said in your
mind that this is someone that's right
for me to work with not just a great
script I I think even that question kind
of shows what a challenge collaboration
is right in that it's so easy to think
oh this person has a good track record
this person has a good script but what
you're saying is this is a long-term
relationship where I need them to be
supportive of me and I need to be
supportive of them I need need to be
able to recognize what they're doing and
I need them to recognize what I'm doing
even if we don't know how we're
balancing that yet I think there's that
question of personality and chemistry in
terms of any relationship you know are
we going to enjoy having dinner together
over the course of these next three five
seven years but then there's also what
the joint project is what is it in this
script or this movie of this story world
series whatever one might be doing what
are the big ideas and can they sustain
me will I find them as intriguing to
talk about years down the road I can't
look at movies as products I can't look
at movies is only profit generators
right I look at movies as essentially
community organizers right how people
are going to come together
what are those ideas themes characters
objects of beauty you know
objects of desire what does it encompass
that's going to keep us you know firing
on all cylinders
synapses across you know the period of
working on it to to make a movie you
need that mix of both
you know mad genius that inspires strong
leadership that brings us forward
careful diplomacy that knows how to make
sure that each side is represented and
there needs a surfaced and fulfilled and
ultimately friendship and joy right you
know that you that when something moves
beyond a job
when it becomes a core aspect of your
life which I think every film is you
better be receiving pleasure from that
you know whether they're new ideas
whether they're taking you to new places
whether they're introducing you to new
people like all those things that's the
what why we're so fortunate to get to
make movies but you have to be able to
appreciate that and sometimes
personalities make that hard sometimes
force of circumstance you know financial
needs makes that hard but I think all of
those things are what makes a good
relationship work
you